[Music]
this
is star talk cosmic queries edition for
the new year
chuck nice co-host jack hey neil happy
new year buddy
happy new year 2021 2021 yay
yeah we made we survived we made it
did you have doubts did you i really did
to be honest
it was many times during 2020 where i
doubted i would see 2021.
there was a turbulent year on many
fronts and
but i try to sort of take stock in the
measures of turbulence that
we experience and then i i look back you
know during the
second world war you know how turbulent
those times were
i mean i could quantify it i
i was not there so you weren't there
okay
but there are books that's why we have
books you can go without
being there i'm sorry that's why i have
you
okay everybody else has books
[Laughter]
all right so between 1939 the beginning
of the war in 1945
1 000 people
per hour were killed
wow because of that war that's um
per power
thought to say the least one of the
great low points
of civilization was the second world war
that at a time when people thought the
first world war was the war
to end all wars so so that's one measure
another measure
i think of the 1960s 1968
in particular with two assassinates two
you know highly um significant
assassinations with with martin luther
king and bobby kennedy
who was then you know declared a
candidate for president right so
it wasn't simply another politician or
influential figure
he was trying to become president and to
the assassinations there was
campus unrest there was uh riots
in the inner cities and wait a minute
now are you sure that wasn't 2020
so here's my point so you look at all
this and
let me tell you something in my circles
the way we think
of 1968 oh by the way let's just set it
straight
that deaths in vietnam peaked in 1968.
okay we were losing 100 servicemen a
week basically that and the tet
offensive
this is the great sort of resistance
that was put to our presence there
on the the chinese new year where no one
thought that they would be
trying to fight back on a day that
everyone would be celebrating
called the ted offensive all that
happened in 1968 okay
and so we uh oh 68 i think was also the
melee massacre
okay do you remember that this is with
you know what
so it was it was terrible ugly that's
the better word it's an ugly
year and i would declare it just by my
own
metrics to be the the most turbulent
bloodiest year of a decade
that was the bloodiest year on american
soil since the 1860s in the civil war
itself that's where so so that's what
1968
represented however all right
in my circles what we know is that in
december
1968 we left earth
for the first time right
we went to the moon in 19 so people
forget this
we left earth and went to the freaking
moon in 1968
apollo 8. now no one remembers them
because they didn't
park on the roof they didn't get out
they they didn't land it's tough to do a
drive-by
nobody it's a drive-by it's a drive-by
nobody nobody nobody nobody gives you
credit for a drive-by
for not getting out of the car that's
right remember remember when bush
flew over katrina oh okay right all
right
yeah so so what he so what we did we
went to the moon
circled it a dozen 15 times and then
came back but in those
orbits that famous photo taken by a
hasselblad camera by the way
nasa was not gonna miss an opportunity
they got the best cameras available
in the day hasselblad camera bam
earthrise right over the moon
and there it was
earth not as we see it in the school
room globe i've talked about this often
you know you you go to school and
there's earth and the
countries are color coded the states are
color coded for goodness sake
all right and there's no clouds it's
just color-coded countries
on this ball and there it is in all of
its natural
majesty a float adrift
in space in the darkness of space and
you see ocean
and land and clouds that picture comes
back
and the astronauts got all emotional and
someone who's religious
read from genesis okay and
and some people complained you know
ardent atheists complain we're using tax
money to put religion in space
i'm thinking they're the first ones ever
to go to moon let him read whatever the
hell he wants
exactly i have no i don't care
what he does okay he's the one that went
to the moon and you didn't
okay so it what was written
about that because that happened at the
end of december
because they were there during christmas
okay okay
is that nasa
saved 1968
wow so
wow nasa saved 1968.
last night a dj saved my life and nasa
saved 1968.
that's pretty cool yeah and so when i
think of 2020
i think uh
are you gonna is there a way that nasa
saved 2020. i don't know if the please
they're not specific please
is there a way um but i think space
has a way of having us all look up oh by
the way that image of earthrise over the
moon
right um for me the most potent
statement
to come out of that whole era birthed
with that photo
is we went to the moon
to explore the moon and we discovered
earth
for the first time that's a beautiful
statement yes
and hopefully one day uh the statement
will be
i went to the moon and all i got was
this lousy t-shirt
because that means that that means that
space travel will be so common
so casual so casual that what you
complain about
right like yeah that would that that
would be a very cool day all right so
so what what happened so there was a
total solar eclipse in the second week
of december
in and that crossed the bottom part of
south america so chile and argentina got
a piece of that
so good for the rest of the americas
there and but not only that on december
21st
the solstice the the december solstice
yeah we the planets jupiter
and saturn and saturn got so close if
you took off your glasses
you'd think there was one object on the
sky it's pretty wild man you know what
for me what was good about that
was the last time anyone saw something
that
close in the sky for those two planets
was 800 years ago
the dark ages or maybe the middle ages i
get my ages
uh confused but back then that is not a
time you wanted to live in
for sure about that yes exactly all
right it was even hard on white people
to be living back there that's when you
know times are rough
that's when you know i said you know
times are rough
okay and so you go back then so we talk
about the year 12
23 or 26 somewhere back then
these two planets got that close
together on the sky so
so to me that says wow you know
it forces you to think back in time when
someone else saw the same kind of
conjunction it's called that you are in
that there was some guy laid out on iraq
being tortured
and he looked somebody was just like is
that jupiter
all our stereotypes of that error
[Music]
everybody was on the rack all right guys
being tortured hey look at that hey
that's kind of interesting
so so uh so i think if it gets you to
look up
and there's a common thing everyone in
the world can see
then i think that has value it
if you want to think if we if we can't
escape our own tribal roots
if tribalism must gurgle up maybe we can
instead
uh think of a tribe as all of
the human species well see then we need
an alien invasion to make that happen
oh you mean like covid oh yeah so maybe
if a virus came to earth
and affected everybody maybe we would
all get together and fight it
in harmony oh yeah yeah good thought
chuck
clear clearly there's no hope for us
okay this is
okay so that was the low point for me it
wasn't even specifically
covet and the economic and social and
personal damage it was causing
it was that it was recognizing that we
as a species did not mobilize
coherently to fight a common invader
that for me was the testing grounds
for an actual alien invasion in case the
aliens wanted to kill all humans
like they do in every science fiction
movie where bad aliens show up
oh man so that's that i was
upset by that and i thought higher of
humanity
i thought we could let's aspire to
higher
goals higher higher positions of of
of wisdom on how we would treat so what
it is we just tribalized again oh i'm an
anti-masculine i'm an anti-vaxxer and
i'm an anti-this and you're that
and my my favorite bit of insight to
come out of that was
just or educational insight is you tell
someone
you know one state is going to open its
borders and the other is not and one
country and this and that but we're all
still traveling a little bit right
what's going on and so like i said it's
like
designating a peeing section of the
swimming pool
okay guys i'll be right back um
no you guys stay right here in the deep
end i gotta make my way down to three
feet and take care of a little business
okay and then i'll come back right and
i'll see you when i
yeah that's that's brilliant exactly i
agree
and so it's insight into how futile
it is to say for one country to say i'm
not going to clean up
this water uh because it's my problem
not your problem it's everybody's
problem because
water travels air travels
okay viruses travel right and in fact
viruses have the benefit that we
invented airplanes just for it
there's no other way a virus could cross
the atlantic
okay virus let me get on this airplane
look at that it's amazing it's like
back in the day so viruses have the most
frequent flyer miles
that's right just like these human
beings are amazing guys
look at what they've done for us
look at all the things they've in venice
to get us where we need to go
was a gary larson comic when you need
one because that would be cool just
the virus express exactly
wow so so i think um
there's there's a saying if someone says
oh it's raining so heavily
yeah it probably that means it will rain
a little less heavily an hour from now
right i mean you know if something is at
its worst
pretty much it can things can only get
better
not a hundred percent of time but most
of the time in fact this is why
weird medical uh cures exist at all
right so you take regular medicine it's
not working for you you got some
intractable problem
and you get worse and worse and worse
and then you get to some
bottom station i can't take this anymore
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna do
the prescribed mess i'm gonna do i'm
gonna have crystals rubbed above my body
when i'm sleeping
okay and then you start getting better
okay because
your body all right well at the low
point you either keep going and die
at which point you don't write the book
about this new cure that you found
or you start getting better by natural
causes but you want to credit whatever
you happen to be doing
while that happened so this is the
susceptibility of our belief systems
when that happens but when things hit
their worst you think maybe they'll get
better so
i can't imagine 2021 being much worse
than this
the and and kudos to medical researchers
for coming up with a vaccine on record
time
yes record time right okay and i was
surprised to learn because i'm not a
medical professional i'm looking up in
the journals
and most of these vaccines for like
smallpox and mumps it took
decades to develop right decades
so so it's not simply that a vaccine
exists
it's that the system sped up that
process
and ideally in the future
vaccines will just be waiting on the
shelf so no matter
what the thing comes in you just tweak
something real fast and bada-bing
doesn't stand a chance right so that'd
be kind of cool the day that happens so
we need to
at least celebrate how quickly this
turned around absolutely
i i can't wait to get my vaccine i don't
care what anybody says
i'll take it publicly you know i as a
matter of fact
i'm i wish i could take somebody's place
right now
let's just jump in front of the line i
wish i could cut the line because i
would do it in a second
did you see some of the early vaccine
videos i think the russians had some
early version
but people were concerned about the side
effects so someone was there and they're
speaking to you and they get the russian
vaccine and halfway through
they start speaking russian yeah
halfway through the interview that's
pretty that was pretty funny i like that
um so anyway so with this is ostensibly
a
cosmic queries yeah we want to be future
leaning
on this okay and so you got you got any
for me i assume we we're still honoring
our patreon
absolutely supporters so of course the
uh we'll call it a new year grab ad for
this one
and uh how about this we'll start off
with gordon vu
from patreon hey dr tyson and dr nice
uh i am wondering i called you dr nice
he called me dr nice to meet you gordon
you're a good man thank you sir don't
don't do that though
don't do that brother chuck in my book
you're a doctor of comedy
oh that's all oh you got me man look at
that
i i didn't know how that was right and i
bet the fan base will agree
i'm just saying okay you got me that was
you get that i'm serious that that
that was unexpected thank you okay uh he
says i am wondering if a light
particle will travel forever
in space if unhindered does light
particles
obey the second law of thermodynamics so
so the is is it is it emotion and
continually in motion
okay so this is forever this is a
question that very much concerns itself
with the future
the future of a particle of light what
we'll do we'll take a quick break and
when we come back to
the new year's edition of cosmic queries
we'll go straight to that question
on star talk
we're back star talk check nice jack hey
so you tweet at a chuck nice comic right
yes sir thank you very much
okay you know what's the the funnest
times when i follow your tweets is
when you were live tweeting some some
important sporting event
you just you're all up in it i love it
he dropped that pass what's wrong with
him and i can
hear you just railing on all what's
going on my favorite is when i'm
following my home team the philadelphia
eagles
uh and you can hear the absolute
um devastating disappointment in the
angst and anguish
yeah because honestly that is the fun of
being
uh an eagles fan learning how to take
disappointment and make it fun this was
this was true for the boston red sox for
so long but then they started winning
and their whole raison d'etre which was
oh we're we
almost get there but not and that's what
bound bound people together
when they started winning it was like
that got lost yeah you can't say it
anymore
i'm hoping to have that experience one
day with the eagles
and for old timers they remember was it
susan lucci who had the record for
never winning a uh daytime emmy for her
uh
for the soap operas that she had
appeared on and so that became the thing
right right
yeah you know are you not going to win
an emmy again this year you know
exactly and then she wanted emmy and
then that whole that whole stick
and her whole career was over
just killed her
so uh we left off with a question about
the faint of a particle of light so
won't you
give me the who asked that again so
gordon bill and he says i'm wondering if
a light particle will travel forever
if left unhindered does a particle of
light obey the second law of
thermodynamics
right so um the a particle of light
uh if so a photon just call it a photon
right
uh if the universe were static
okay so if it were just stationary not
expanding not shrinking
and it's just there and if it were
infinite
and then out comes a particle of light
that particle that photon will travel
forever
unhindered and unimpeded
travel forever okay it's not gaining
complexity it's not losing it's just
travel
however we live in an expanding universe
and in an expanding universe the photon
which also can be thought of
as having a wavelength of light
as it moves through an expanding
universe that wavelength
gets stretched embedded in the fabric
of the stretching universe itself and
when you stretch
light you give it longer wavelength the
distance between crests right when i say
wave i mean the natural thing you think
of in a wave there's
you know there's a hill and a valley so
the distance from crest to crest that's
a full wave length
that stretches that reduces
the energy of the photon so the photon
in this universe
approaches lower and lower energy and if
it started out as a blue photon
you then become uh it goes backwards
back through the spectrum
becomes a red photon then a microwave
photon a radio photon
and then in the very distant future its
wavelength could be
miles long you know far out of your
capacity to see with the naked eye or
any of our equipment
and and the fate of the universe uh
just descends into this a long
wavelength uh
graveyard
wow have a nice day yeah
sorry photon sorry folk time
but i gotta throw this out there i gotta
throw this out there you may know from
relativity
that the faster you go the slower time
ticks for you
as seen by others who watch this so this
is relative to the relativity of time
so it travels ticks slower and slower
and slower so the faster you go
the slower time takes and this just
continues and continues and continues
right if you hit the speed of light
time stops no time right no time for you
for you right it'll look like everything
else around you
is speeding up okay so the photon
has no cons itself has no concept of
time
so if a photon is emitted by your
flashlight
even and you point it out in space
okay that photon will travel forever
until it hits something right and the
moment it hits something
the photon will say to itself boy that
was quick i was just admitted by a
flashlight
right exactly because no time elapses
for that photon
so it doesn't matter how long it travels
as far as it's concerned
it was emitted and absorbed
instantaneously in the same instant
look at that that's very cool
freak freaky photons who knew we would
get all that out of
gordon booze that's amazing
all right all right keep it coming let's
go to josh uh
josh v he says
uh hey dr tyson how did star talk come
about
and how did you get chuck involved
[Laughter]
i i don't know if he's about to lodge a
complaint
or not yeah that's unclear that is
unclear right we don't know
and then he says uh how many folks work
behind the scenes to bring us these
episodes can you give a shout out to the
folks
off the camera who makes star talk uh
possible and this is uh
um andrei
so there you go wow wow okay
i would do better if i had a list so
that i can just rattle them off what i
can say is
um and in fact i'm i'm a little
disappointed in myself because i was on
a podcast just recently
in fact i was on uh nagin farsad's
part podcast yeah yes and her
podcast is fake the nation and at the
end of the podcast
she went through the list of everybody
who makes that show the producers the
writers i hate when they do that
and i said i don't i hate when i'm
listening
but now i'm thinking i got people we got
people who make this happen
exactly and i never read their names on
the list well
listen there's a reason why you're
behind the scenes okay
okay let's just
all right run some credits run
credits at the end okay and do like they
do with tv they just
fl critics fly by
so uh start so it's a great question
thank you
for thinking about this because you know
there are people behind the scenes
so a star talk was an idea that
came about about 12 years ago actually
and helen matsos who's a co-executive
producer
with me and there's a third fellow named
david gamble who's not no longer part of
the
organization but the three of us um
applied
for a grant from the national science
foundation
the three of us applied for a grant from
the national science foundation
on the grounds that we think we can
create
a radio program that can bring science
to the public
and have sponsors want to support it
there were already radio programs that
dealt with science but they're like on
npr
right and so every quarter you've got to
beg for money and
so how why do you have to do that oh
because it's that science is good for
you but not good for
good for marketing okay so we were
living with this expectation that you
could not sell
science but i said to myself i've seen
people react when i talk to them about
science and cool things and black holes
and
and i know this but not only that
there's science everywhere
so maybe let's fold in some fun
celebrity guests
real celebrities like authentic people
that everybody knows of
and talk about the way science has
touched their lives
so instead of a journalist interviewing
a scientist let's have a scientist
interview
folks pulled in from random places
that scientists would meet and then
bring the other and i know
from my life trying to educate is that
if you make people smile
no not and make them smile that sounds
like it's a force if you
if if you if they enjoy the moment
they're more likely to remember what
happened in that moment so we said to
ourselves we want to combine
celebrities with comedians
and i will have the steering wheel on
this conversation
and i will have also dials to dial up or
down the comedian and up or down
the there and i will we can deliver a
a a persistently uh reliable combination
of content with gravity and content with
levity
and that would then become the dna of
star talk
we thought we'd get uh become
commercially viable in three years as a
three-year grant
but it would take an extra two years and
which we got an extension grant from the
alfred p
sloan foundation which is very big into
science and
and the public and at in the fifth year
we finally
drew in enough money from advertisers to
pay all of what
we have so we have uh producers we have
writers what the writers do is they come
up they say okay
we have this guest why don't we talk
about this and so
they're not scripting words that are
coming out of you and my mouth but
they're
it was their idea to to have the topics
that we
um identify so for example we just
posted uh at the end of last year we
posted an interview with olivia munn
okay i knew of her as an actress and but
i didn't know her whole profile that
then
the work she did in an x-men and she's a
geek herself
so we got researchers who establish all
that and they prepare those notes for me
and i drive the bus
from and i know which way to turn from
the notes that we have a team of writers
do for us
and researchers so there's that then
there are people who maintain the
internet we have someone
the name is jeff simons who is the
cultivator of the patreon community all
right
so and he also writes the fan page for
star talk telling you what's coming up
what just happened what to look forward
to so the
whole fan interactive dimension of that
uh is covered there we have someone else
who posts to to twitter and to the and
to instagram and to facebook and we only
recently opened up tiktok
uh so uh star talks tick tock is
primarily me but we're gonna find ways
that others
can contribute to that who are part of
the the family so all told
there's about 15 people
uh behind the scenes and i have not only
chuck as a comedian
but we have three or four other
comedians that are kind of out in the
wings
if chuck can't make it because he's got
his own he's got a day job
check do you have a danger yes i work at
payless shoes
okay they went out of business i think
that's why okay
okay maybe they didn't i don't know but
the one across my street that's why i
said this
because they went well that's why you
said it so
chuck we can't have chuck every minute
of his life so we have some other
comedians and you've seen them
and you've heard them and we love them
all
eugene merman was an early comedian in
this but then he moved out of town up to
boston
and we tapped into the eugene merman's
comedy festival
which gave us access to other comedians
and so
uh and the very first comedian for star
talk was lynn coplets
uh and uh and so
so that's what we've been and over that
time of course the landscape has changed
where um terrestrial radio which is
where we began
then gave way to uh podcasts
and then we had a stint on siriusxm
and so now we have our youtube channel
with more than a million
followers so the radio show concept is
grown into
of course we video all of our radio
shows now so that you can consume them
in both
media so so that's that's the total
um structure of this and the one closest
to what you're experiencing now
is lindsay walker lindsay's behind the
scenes one day maybe we should take a
family picture
and then we'll put it up and have little
uh you know face identify everybody
so there's not only lindsey walker but
we also have lucy
long who uh does some of the sort of
normal star talks but then she does all
the rest of the star talk sports
editions
so we got people all plugged in to the
operations
of the star talk enterprise and so
it's it's an entire community and i mean
i was embarrassed that i have never read
that list
and so what i might here's what i'll do
uh i'm gonna
we're gonna run credits
or at least part of a show i'm going to
devote at least five or ten minutes
to just introducing each one of them and
they all come on and say hi to everybody
and that way you'll get to see the star
talk family we'll do it do a show
just of that okay i'm i'm just
where did we find chuck he was uh he was
panhandling on this street
i was tell a joke for five dollars no uh
neil met me on the subway i was like
excuse me ladies and gentlemen of the
subway
i mean you no disrespect
my favorite joke from the the homeless
subway comedian have you seen him
my favorite joke of his was i'm so broke
i can't even pay attention right
that was good yeah so uh my my guy
uh so uh that guy is on the b
train oh you already know what train the
dudes
that guy's on the b train uh the six
train dude is just like
what's the best nation in the world a
donation hello
hello yeah
well i figure if they can make me laugh
you know i don't mind give him a couple
of dollars
i mean if i pay to see a comedian in a
comedy club um
if he doesn't happen to have access to a
comedy club right or his comedy club is
the captive audience of a subway train i
don't
mind slipping them a couple of dollars i
hate all the cops and
okay where it comes from we don't like
it so give me give me another fast one
before we take a break
oh man that's a tough one here we go
fast here it is uh john jacobson
what would the impact be to the current
theories in cosmology if the speed of
light at the beginning of the universe
was
faster than it is observed to be
now and even slower in the distant
future
oh wow okay i like that
i like it so much we have to take a
break and we'll come back
so when we come back we will find out
the implications of a change in the
speed of light on star talk
cosmic queries we're back star talk
cosmic query is the new year's edition
we're trying to think of the future
trying to leave the past behind us yes
water
under the bridge please yeah
so a question was what would be
different if the speed of light
were not constant so let me let me
make a very stark
statement here okay first we have never
measured the speed of light to be
anything different
than it is in the laboratory okay
now because when we look out in space
we look back in time we have ways
of measuring the speed of light
in those locations right back in time
so so we can make measurements
that apply at a different place at a
different time
when we measure the speed of light there
and then it's the same value that we get
on my
uh in my laboratory i believe that's why
they call it a
constant
the constant to end all constants and so
you might say well how do we measure the
speed of light
way back there's several ways but let me
tell you an interesting one it's called
the fine structure constant this is a
ratio of other constants
that tells us how the energy separates
in the
levels of atoms and so
the separation of those energy levels if
a light enters or exits the atom
that affects the spectrum okay
so if the fine structure constant were
different
in the early universe than it is today
or any of those constants
then then the spectral features
of atomic elements in the early universe
would look different
from how they do today but they are
exactly
the same carbon in the first few moments
of the universe
is leaving the same spectral signature
as it does today
and that spectral signature has the
speed of light built into it
for it to give us what it is we see that
is amazing it is it is a
it's amazing it's it's it's not was not
obvious and by the way
this is we're not just assuming the
speed of light was the same but we
we we have we intermittently pose the
question
all right and consider that isaac newton
wondered you know my my law of gravity
is
busting ass right it's got the earth
around the moon around the earth and
earth around the sun jupiter's moons
going around jupiter
it's a badass theory of gravity newton's
theory of gravity then he said but does
it apply beyond
neptune the last known planet that does
it apply to other stars
so this was an open question until we
could measure
the speed of binary stars elsewhere in
the galaxy and they were following
newton's laws
then we measured galaxies and we find
out they were
following newton's law so so when you
add all this together
yes these things are constant not only
in
place but in time and only in time but
in place
so so that's my first comment in
response to that question my
second is so fundamental is our
understanding of the universe
invoking the fact the observed fact that
the speed of light does not change
that if somehow the speed of light
started changing up on us
um to say how would it affect cosmology
it affects everything
everything i would sign we'd have to
like start science all over again
that's that's how that's how significant
such a fact would be so i don't
that's that's my answer you know it's
not oh we'll have to rethink this but
not that
no everything right everything wow
okay maybe biology probably wouldn't be
different i i
would suspect uh and but chemistry we'd
have to understand
the fine structure constant would have
been different what would chemistry look
like back then
compared to now molecules would be
different okay because the energy levels
the energy levels of atoms of energy
levels of electrons in atoms are what
dictate
how strongly molecules are held together
right oh my gosh that's amazing
so so thank you for making the very
clear point that
uh speed of light uses the symbol c
because it is the mother of all
constants yeah
very nice e equals m c
t squared
there you go all right that sounds so
cool man all right
let's go to
[Music]
yolina no walk i think it's you lena
you lena okay i hope that's your name
uh we should take up a collection we
should take patreon money
and take up a collection to give chuck
pronunciation lessons
no no see here's what people don't
understand people
people send me all kinds of stuff
they're like hey this'll help you with
names and hey
this will help you pronounce and here's
what you're failing to realize
i don't care okay
if you want your name pronounced
correctly send me
the phonetic pronunciation of your name
along with your name
otherwise just have fun listening to me
struggle
as i tried to figure out what the hell
your name is
[Laughter]
all right so all right next one she says
or
he says uh what would the advantage
who yulina i think yulina nowak
what with the advantages uh or
disadvantages
of living on a gas giant
cheers from poland excellent uh
excellent uh in fact being the
advantages of living on a
gas giant so my recent book was just
translated into polish
and i just did an interview on polish
television nice
regarding that yeah yeah they spoke they
spoke english to me i don't know
polish and they'll apologize and that
the english wasn't good i say
dude i don't know any polish at all so
don't apologize to me for whatever it is
you're doing the english
okay guess what and and that's this is
what lets you know you're american
okay you go to any nation in the world
and you
try to speak their language and they
look at you like look at how you butcher
my language
they tell you that in english look at
how you put you in my language
you come to america and you can only say
five words all right but you're just
like please
you two tell me how to train
bathroom yes to tell me how to
and we go oh my god your english is so
good
why don't you learn to speak english
because we know we can't speak their
life but that's what we know
that's what it is right all right all
right so now i forgot the damn question
gas giant advantages that's right so
there are two ways you can think about
that question one of them is
maybe we could live on a moon that is
orbiting a gas giant
okay because they're moons we know moons
that have atmospheres they're moons that
have water around jupiter and around
saturn so liquid water by the way that's
way outside the goldilocks zone
if you're orbiting jupiter way outside
the comfort zone where earth is
where we can sustain liquid water not
too close you evaporate and not too far
you freeze
right out there it's freezing but
there's an
energy source which is this sort of
symphony of
tidal forces among the moons and of the
main planet that
that that stresses the physical object
that is the moon
and when you squeeze it and unsqueeze it
and squeeze it on screen you're actually
pumping energy into it
much the same way when you if you play
racquetball you say let's warm up the
ball
by hitting it multiple times you deform
the ball the ball
recovers its shape and every time you do
that you're pumping energy
and you literally warm the ball that's
what's happening to europa
that's what's happening to io these are
moons in the outer planets
and in fact io has raging volcanoes
from energy that have been pumped in by
this
thought this process so we have sources
of energy
so the gravity of the big planet or the
jazz guy
like the jazz guy the gas the jazz giant
[Laughter]
is causing the moon
or the other body to undulate in such a
way
that it creates heat yes
wow deep in its interior and so on
europa
which may have a kilometer deep layer of
ice because it's sitting outside of the
goldilocks zone
right deep inside there's evidence that
there's an
ocean of liquid water that might have
more water than all the oceans
of earth wow so
yes so what you do is you move to one of
these moons and then maybe introduce an
atmosphere or
or go to one that already has an
atmosphere titan one of the moons
the largest moon of saturn one of the
largest moons in the whole solar system
has a thick atmosphere except it's an
atmosphere of methane
which is the gas that comes out of your
stove um and so
i'm sorry and
[Music]
thank you for the physiological addition
to my car
i just i just want to make a
contribution thank you for your
scientific addition you're correct
scientific yes uh methane is the product
of
bacteria that metabolizes in the absence
of oxygen
and your entire gut intestines right on
through
uh it has there's no oxygen there so
that's anaerobic
non-um oxygen thriving bacteria
and so one of their byproducts is
methane so yes in camp when they wanted
to light your fart
on fire there's science behind that
okay come on baby okay
and those of you who are old-timers with
star talk chuck you and i talked about
this was it five years ago
we talked about a new uh a new talent
that
superman superman could could exploit
because if he's if
he's a superhuman in every way then he
would have super farts
and yes if that's the case he could you
know he would remember how
he can blow on something and freeze it
well if he lights one of his
farts you can you can ignite an entire
village
my favorite probably to this damn still
my favorite conversation we have ever
had
flap and the buttons on the back and you
pull the flap down
and you look back oh god
it's amazing it's awesome
it's science it's what it is oh god
all right so let me talk science like
this in school
it'd be the best kids would never ever
get turned off
all right so why do we start talking
about methane well because it's about
so titan methane right and
methane is only flammable if it's in the
presence of oxygen
so so people worried that the spacecraft
would ignite the entire atmosphere of
titan
because we landed there uh europe had a
probe that landed there called huygens
and
um but no not a problem but anyhow so
you can live in a moon that orbits one
of these planets provided it's been
warmed by this tidal force because we
need a source of energy
for our own metabolism and we have to
figure out you know is it plant life is
it animal life
maybe these oceans in europa have fishes
swimming in them
all right so you can go ice fishing
there that could be fun so
so that's a new opening of the
goldilocks zone that we previously
hadn't considered
when we were restricting our search for
just that
golden distance um from the host star
so in terms of the gas giant itself
without a surface to walk on and with
the
um plus the gre and if he did have a
surface the gravity is very high
so i can't think of i can't i cannot
endorse
any urges to live in the atmosphere of a
gas giant because most of their mass is
in the form of gas
oh wow look at that that's amazing yeah
so chuck i
think we have to end it there that went
fast oh my god that was like
some some fun questions just to begin
the new year and
uh so chuck a happy and healthy new year
for you and your family
thank you same to you my friend yeah i'm
just trying to keep the universe
bring the universe to try to bring the
universe down to earth
for whoever will listen all right
there you go all right i'm neil degrasse
tyson bidding all of you happy new year
happy 2021 may it be better for you than
it
ever was for any of us in 2020 let me
tell you something
if your 2021 is worse than 2020
just give up yeah yeah it's time to give
up on that time to give up
go to another planet exactly it's like
i'm out of here
all right uh this has been star talk
cosmic aquarius new year's edition
neil degrasse tyson keep looking up
[Music]